>>> STEPHANIE GRISHAM SPENT
YEARS AT DONALD TRUMP'S SIDE.
SHE WAS FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PRESS SECRETARY, AND THEN CHIEF
OF STAFF FOR FIRST LADY MELANIA
TRUMP BEFORE QUITTING HER JOB,
IN PROTEST AFTER THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
NOW, PLEASE REMEMBER, STEPHANIE
GRISHAM NEVER HELD A PRESS
BRIEFING AS PRESS SECRETARY.
BUT NOW SHE'S READY TO TALK IN A
NEW TELL-ALL MEMOIR, WHICH
DETAILS HER TIME INSIDE THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
IN ONE PASSAGE, GRISHAM RECALLS
HOW TRUMP CATERED TO PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN TELLING HIM I'M
GOING TO ACT A LITTLE TOUGH FOR
YOU FOR A FEW MINUTES BUT
THEY'RE FOR THE CAMERAS.
AFTER THEY LEAVE, WE'LL TALK.
YOU UNDERSTAND?
THAT'S NOT A SURPRISE, ANNA.
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, YOU
AND I, OFTEN, THAT HE WAS SO
DIFFERENTIAL TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS A SUPER FAN
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S.
NOW WE KNOW THAT WHATEVER
BLUSTER HE CLAIMED, THAT HE WAS
SO TOUGH ON VLADIMIR PUTIN,
BEFOREHAND HE WHISPERED TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, I'M FAKING IT
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
NOT MUCH IN THIS BOOK THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
IT'S JUST REMINDING US OF ALL
THE DYSFUNCTION WE ALREADY KNEW
ABOUT AND SAW IN FRONT OF US.
I AM TROUBLED BY THE BOOK, THE
NATURE OF THE BOOK IN GENERAL.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> AND ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WHO,
ALL OF A SUDDEN, RESIGNED IN
PROTEST ON JANUARY 6th AFTER SHE
WITNESSED ALL THESE THINGS,
AFTER SHE WITNESSED HIM
COWTAILING TO PUTIN.
IT'S A LITTLE LATE.
AND THE TITLE OF THE BOOK IS
INCREDIBLY CYNICAL.
>> "I'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS
NOW."
>> AFTER SHE DIDN'T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE ENTIRE TIME SHE
WAS PRESS SECRETARY.
IT IS CYNICAL AND EMPHASIZING
SHE DIDN'T TAKE QUESTIONS AS A
PRESS SECRETARY.
NOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BUY MY
BOOK AND YOU'RE GOING TO PAY ME,
NOW MAYBE I WILL ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS AND SPILL ALL THE TEA.
WELL, GIRLFRIEND, IT'S A DAY
LATE AND A DOLLAR SHORT.
>> I'M GLAD YOU POINT THAT OUT.
WE COULD HAVE USED SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
THAT DOES RAISE THE QUESTION,
NATASHA, OF WHY SO FEW PEOPLE IN
MELANIA TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE,
PEOPLE WHO SHE ONCE CONSIDERED
CLOSE FRIENDS AND CONSIDERED HER
CLOSE FRIENDS HAVE NO LOYALTY TO
HER.
ACID, AFTERWARDS THEY ARE
WILLING TO DISCUSS WHAT THEY
SAW.
WHY DOES SHE INSPIRE SUCH LACK
OF LOYALTY IN THE PEOPLE AROUND
HER?
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THE PASSAGES WE SAW IN THE BOOK,
FRANKLY, SHE WASN'T THAT
INSPIRING.
SHE WAS PORTRAYED AS A FIRST
LADY WHO WAS QUITE SELF
CENTERED, WHO WAS PRETTY PETTY,
WHO TOOK JABS AT BOTH THE MEDIA
AND HER HUSBAND, DUE TO, YOU
KNOW, RUMORS OF HIS
INFIDELITIES.
AND, YOU KNOW, JUST IN GENERAL
DID NOT HAVE THAT ATTITUDE OF
SERVICE YOU WOULD EXPECT FROM A
FIRST LADY.
BUT I AGREE WITH ANA.
THERE'S SO MUCH HYPOCRISY WITH
STEPHANIE GRISHAM, WHO ONCE
ATTACKED THE MEDIA AS BEING
BIASED.
NOW LOOK WHO HAS A BOOK DEAL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT COURAGE.
THIS IS VERY MUCH ABOUT
THERE'S STILL SOME JUICY STUFF
IN THERE.
SO HERE'S ONE.
>> I HATE THE BOOK, I HATE THE
CYNICISM BUT GIVE ME THE TEETH.
>> THIS IS ABOUT THE STORMY
DANIELS STUFF.
SHE HAD A FRONT ROW SEAT ON
EVERYTHING THAT WAS GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES WHEN THE
STORMY DANIELS STUFF BROKE, AND
SO HERE'S WHAT SHE WRITES, AFTER
THE STORMY DANIELS STORY BROKE
AND ALL OF THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
FOLLOWED FROM OTHER WOMEN, I
FELT MRS. TRUMP WAS BASICALLY
UNLEASHED.
SHE HAD ALWAYS BEEN INDEPENDENT
FROM HER HUSBAND, NOW AS A
WRONGED AND PUBLICLY HUMILIATED
FIRST LADY SHE SEEMED LIBERATED
TO DO WHATEVER SHE WANTED OR
DIDN'T WANT TO DO BUT ANA, AS WE
ALL REMEMBER.
ONE OF THE THINGS SHE WANTED TO
DO WAS WEAR A JACKET THAT SAID I
DON'T REALLY CARE, DO YOU, WHEN
SHE WENT TO MEET WITH CHILDREN,
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AT THE
BORDER.
THIS WAS HER BIG EXPRESSION OF
HER INNER THOUGHTS HERE.
>> THERE WERE A LOT OF
EXPRESSIONS OF HER INNER
THOUGHTS.
THERE WAS TIMES SHE DIDN'T GO
WITH HIM TO CERTAIN EVENTS, SHE
SLAPPED AWAY HIS HAND.
WE ALL REMEMBER THAT
DYSFUNCTION.
WE THOUGHT BILL AND HILLARY GAVE
US SOMETHING TO TALK ABOUT.
THIS WAS ALSO PRETTY -- YOU SAW
A DYSFUNCTIONAL MARRIAGE ON
DISPLAY, THE PRESIDENCY IS A
FISH BOWL, AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE EXACERBATED AND BEING
COVERED 24 HOURS A DAY.
I DON'T THINK SHE MADE MANY
EFFORTS, MELANIA, IN HIDING
ANGER AND DISPLEASURE.
>> SPEAKING OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
BEHAVIOR AROUND OTHER WOMEN,
HERE'S AN INTERESTING NUGGET WE
HAVEN'T HEARD BEFORE, THERE WAS
APPARENTLY THIS YOUNG ATTRACTIVE
PRESS AIDE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACTED SO LECHEROUSLY AROUND THIS
PERSON, ACCORDING TO STEPHANIE
GRISHAM.
GRISHAM ALLEGES THAT TRUMP
BECAME OBSESSED WITH A YOUNG
FEMALE PRESS AIDE WHO WAS NOT
NAMED IN THE BOOK.
THE PRESIDENT CONSTANTLY ASKED
WHERE THE AIDE WAS AND ALLEGEDLY
ONCE REQUESTED SHE BE BROUGHT TO
HIS CABIN ON AIR FORCE ONE SO HE
COULD LOOK AT HER BUTT,
BASICALLY.
I MEAN, NOT SURPRISING, BUT THIS
IS THE KIND OF THING THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT FROM, YOU KNOW, A
MIDDLE SCHOOLBOY, NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
NATASHA?
>> NOTHING SURPRISING ABOUT IT,
RIGHT, AND YET HIS FOLLOWERS,
THEY WOULD ELECT HIM NO MATTER
WHAT, RIGHT?
WE SAW GRABBING WOMEN BY THE
PRIVATE PARTS.
HE MOCKED RAPE ACCUSERS BY
SAYING THAT THEY WEREN'T
ATTRACTIVE ENOUGH TO BE
ASSAULTED.
I MEAN, THERE IS NOTHING HERE
THAT IS SURPRISING BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK IS REALLY SOME
INTERESTING TEA IS THE WAY THAT
MELANIA TRUMP RESPONDED TO
STEPHANIE GRISHAM'S ACCUSATIONS.
BOTH OF THE TRUMPS KIND OF TOOK
THIS MISOGYNISTIC STANCE TOWARDS
HER, AND ESSENTIALLY SAID, WELL,
YOU KNOW, SHE'S HAD FAILED
RELATIONSHIPS.
SHE WAS BITTER FROM A BREAK
UP AND MELANIA TRUMP FALLING IN
LINE WITH MISOGYNY AND FALLING
IN LINE WITH HER HUSBAND'S
POLITICAL AGENDA.
>> THEY HAD HER AROUND FOR
YEARS, RIGHT, THIS IS NOT, AS
TRUMP USUALLY DOES, WHO IS THAT,
A COFFEE BOY OR COFFEE GIRL.
SHE WAS AROUND IN ONE CAPACITY
OR ANOTHER IN TRUMP WORLD, TRUMP
POLITICAL WORLD FOR YEARS, AND
LOOK, I DON'T EVEN THINK IT'S
TRUMP ACTING AS A HIGH SCHOOL
BOY.
I THINK IT'S TRUMP ACTING AS
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT VIGNETTE YOU TALKED ABOUT
HARKENS BACK TO MISS UNIVERSE,
HE WOULD WALKING INTO THE
DRESSING ROOM TO SEE ALL OF THE
WOMEN GETTING DRESSED.
IT HARKENS BACK TO HIM RAIDING
WOMEN, GIVING THEM A RANK OF
SHE'S A TEN, SHE'S AN EIGHT,
SHE'S A SIX, SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S
VERY TYPICAL OF DONALD TRUMP,
AND AGAIN, IT JUST GOES BACK TO
REMIND US WHAT A HORRIBLE,
DISGUSTING, LECHEROUS MAN WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> I DO FEEL THE NEED TO READ
HIS STATEMENT ON HER BOOK, WHICH
IS TOO BAD THAT SLEAZEBAG
PUBLISHERS CONTINUE TO REPORT
THIS VERY BORING GARBAGE.
WE IN THE MAGA MOVEMENT ARE
TOTALLY USED TO IT, AND SOME DAY
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE,
WE WILL HAVE OUR VOICE BACK AND
BE TREATED FAIRLY BY THE PRESS.
THE STATEMENT BY DONALD TRUMP.
ABOUT THAT, JUST ONE LAST THING
BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
ABOUT THE RAPE ACCUSATION FROM
E. JEAN CAROL.
HE TOLD HER, DONALD TRUMP TOLD
HER JUST DENY IT, HE DIDN'T DO
IT, HE LOOKED AT HER IN THE
FACE, JUST DENY IT.
THAT WAS HIS STRATEGY.
AND BEFORE I LET YOU GO, I WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
AT THE VIEW, YOU GOT A FALSE
POSITIVE.
YOU HAD NO COVID, YOU WERE NOT
INFECTED BY COVID, YOU FEEL
GREAT.
>> ALISYN, I HAVE HAD LITERALLY
SEVEN TESTS SINCE THAT FALSE
POSITIVE ON FRIDAY.
I MEAN, RIGHT NOW I FEEL LIKE
I'M THE MOST TESTED HUMAN IN
AMERICA.
MY NOSTRILS ARE RAW, AND WE'RE
GOOD.
SO I CAN SIT HERE TELLING YOU
I'M NEGATIVE.
IT WAS A FLUKE, IT WAS A
MISTAKE.
ADVOCACY AWKWARD.
IT WAS EMBARRASSING.
I FEEL TERRIBLE WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE, AND THEY
WERE GREAT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE
REALLY, YOU KNOW, ROLLED WITH
THE PUNCHES, STUCK AROUND, TRIED
TO MAKE IT WORK.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE IT.
WE SAW HER IN THE SATELLITE
OFFICE WITH HER EARPHONES IN.
SINCE THEN, HER OFFICE HAS SAID
THEY FELT DUPED BY THE VIEW
BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN ASSURED
THEY HAD TESTED NEGATIVE.
DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT,
THAT THEY HAD BEEN TOLD BY THAT?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
WE GOT TESTED.
I DO KNOW THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
DID REQUEST WE GET TESTED 24
HOURS OUT FROM THE INTERVIEW,
AND THAT DID HAPPEN.
WE GOT TESTED RIGHT AFTER THE
SHOW ON THURSDAY.
AFTER THAT, YOU KNOW, ALL I DO
IS LEND MY VOICE AND LEND MY
NOSTRILS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE TEST RESULTS, AND I WASN'T
AT THE POINT OF CONTACT WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND LOOK, IF THEY
ARE ANGRY, FRANKLY I THINK AND,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE VEXED, I THINK
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO BE, AND
I KNOW THAT PEOPLE AT THE VIEW,
INCLUDING MYSELF FEEL BAD
BECAUSE I THINK THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT INTERVIEW FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT INTERVIEW
FOR US, AND WE HAD WORKED VERY
HARD TO PUT IT ON THE AIR, TO
ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS, RELEVANT
QUESTIONS, AND I HOPE THAT WE
GET THE CHANCE.
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT INTERVIEW
FOR OUR AUDIENCE TO SEE THE
FIRST FEMALE VICE PRESIDENT GIVE
HER FIRST INTERVIEW, AND REALLY,
IT JUST, YOU KNOW.
>> IT WAS ALSO UNFORTUNATE, I
HEAR YOU.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
>> I'M BUMMED ABOUT THE ENTIRE
THING.
>> I GET I